I think there's two times the door to
the subconscious mind opens up when we
wake up in the morning and we go to bed
at night and it's simple brain chemistry
and simple physiology we have a
circadian rhythm soon as there's light
our body has been pretty much programmed
that we begin to release serotonin
different chemicals that kind of wake us
up so our brain waves go from Delta to
Theta to Alpha to Beta And you kind of
slide up this way and then you're back
to conscious awareness local in space
and time when you go to bed at night you
go from beta to Alpha to Theta to Delta
and you slide down now if you're
stressed you can't stop thinking you
stay in beta your thinking actually is
arousing the body because you're
thinking about your problems you can't
slide down those two points in the day
when we wake up in the morning we go to
bed at night when we're in when alpha or
our analytical facilities are suppressed
we're in Theta we're in a hypnotic State
and the door between the conscious mind
and the subconscious mind is wide open
and what separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind is the
analytical mind so as you suppress
analytical facilities you can program
anybody to do anything hey it's EV
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need it I need it for me
because I don't wake up every day and
say yes let's go conquer the world now I
wake up and and I need that external
motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's open the door
to our subconscious Minds with Dr Joe
dispenser
[Music]
enjoy what really happens for most
people before they even reach for their
cell phone and by the way the statistics
are
86% of the people in the western world
first thing first thing they do is they
reach for the cell phone and they
connect to everything that's known and
why is that a problem well I would never
tell people how to think but I would
give them information to cause them to
think so so the device is reminding them
of things that are known and every
person every object everything every
place is mapped neurologically in our
brain because we've experienced it and
then we have an emotion associated with
our coworker with our boss with our ex
with our whoever and so the moment we
start
responding now we start feeling the same
way so now the
environment is actually controlling the
person's feelings and thoughts yeah and
anything that controls the way we feel
and the way we think we're victims to so
something's programming us to think and
feel a certain way there's nothing wrong
with that you you should check your text
but and do whatever you need to do but
the first thing in the morning if the
door between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind is open why don't we
program a new Behavior why don't we
rehearse a different way of being with
our children with our spouse uh in our
Zoom meetings when we're alone when
we're in traffic is there a better way
to evolve our experience so if you're
truly in the game of evolution you're
truly in the game like one lifetime one
day what am I working on today can I
respond a different way to this person
um can I think this way instead of that
way let me be conscious of my
unconscious thoughts let me not be in a
habit let me stay away from certain
emotions let me practice feeling these
emotions see if I can maintain it now
you're in the game you're out of the
bleachers and you're on the playing
field so it actually happens even before
the cell phone because what most people
do is they wake up and the first thing
they do is the brain is a record of the
past they think of their problems and
those problems are just memories that
are etched in the brain that are
connected to certain people and objects
at certain times and places the moment
they think of their problems are
thinking in the past then when they
think about their problems and they feel
unhappy now their body's in the past and
if you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny yeah
wow and then the emotion that's
associated is now the body's in the past
because thoughts of the language of of
the brain and feelings are the language
of the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being now
here's the problem if you can't think
greater than how you
feel and you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
and you understand that feelings and
emotions a record of the past then
you're thinking in the past and your
life will stay the same rule number two
is reframe your reality being victimized
by a circumstance in your life literally
means that that that event that
circumstance that person
that condition is actually causing you
to feel emotionally and think in terms
of memories equal to that circumstance
and that circumstance is actually
changes your state of being so you're
thinking the same way and you're feeling
the same way and your response to the
environment is the same we can guarantee
that your life is going to stay the same
because you're the same you ask that
person why are you unhappy why are you
frustrated why are you you sad they'll
say the this condition this this person
is actually making me feel and think
this way well anything that makes us
feel and think a certain way that we
don't think we have any control over for
the most part we're victims so we're as
a species become victimized by the
conditions in our life and it's the
environment then that is controlling the
way we feel and the way we think so the
idea is if you can change the way you
think and change the way you feel could
you begin to produce outcomes or effects
in your life that cause you to believe
that you're the creator of your life
instead of the victim of your life which
means then you would have to think
greater than that circumstance and you
would have to feel differently in the
presence of that circumstance and if you
truly could and begin to create an
outcome the synchronicity the
Serendipity the coincidence that happens
in your life you're going to pay
attention to what you did and you're
going to realize that on some level you
had a hand in that you know that you
were a participant in that our interest
is to teach people how to to to reverse
that
process every person every circumstance
every condition every place every object
that you own is mapped neurologically in
your brain so your brain is a record of
the past it's it's an artifact the
repository of everything you've learned
intellectually or experienced and
products of experience are called
emotions the memories that we have in
our life produces familiar emotions or
our response to anybody that we know in
our life there's a neurological Network
for your boss for your coworker for your
ex and for most people their their their
interaction in the environment is
causing their environment that control
their thinking or their personal reality
is controlling their personality so our
interest to see is of well if your
personality is made of how you think how
you act and how you feel is it is it
possible if I begin to change the way I
think change the way I act and change
the way I I feel should my life change
it because I'm changing and so the
interest for us then is to be able to
meet the challenges and conditions in
our life from a greater level of
Consciousness and and not be victimized
uh by those circumstances but to take
time and and to review how you're going
to think how you're going to act and how
you're going to feel that's
meditation and review how you're not
going to think you know how you're not
going to act and how you're not going to
feel it just turns out that tends to be
95% of who we are of those unconscious
programs so it's so much easier to
forget than to remember because it's the
majority of who we are you know after a
certain point in our life so changing
that process the overcoming process of
that same self somehow begins to produce
effects in people's lives and that's
that's kind of the exciting part about
being a creator of your life also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there Ru number three is
reinvent yourself I think the greatest
relationship that you could ever have is
with
yourself uh and taking time to be in the
presence of yourself and ask yourself
important questions like are you happy
who am I and instead of getting up and
getting on your cell phone and getting
distracted sit with your triple filtered
water or a glass of wine or whatever
you're into JJ sit down and answer the
question without being distracted the
contemplation process is the building
process
neurologically and for me I was I was
just a guy I'm a guy who loves God I'm a
guy who loves the Divine I'm the guy who
loves mystery I'm the guy who just never
stops dovetailing information I'm that's
just me and I never really planned on
doing any of this I mean my theories on
life is make it up as you go along and
take the value and run and and what the
bleep became a sensation
and and all of a sudden I went from a
normal guy to being a rock
star and I was traveling around the
world and doing conferences all over the
place and I reached this point where I
realized that I wasn't living the
work and that really bothered me I was
disturbed by that I was really
uncomfortable and when you get
uncomfortable and nothing's making that
discomfort go away it's time to evolve
it's time to make a different choice and
I I clearly heard in my head during one
meditation stop making making the same
choices and pause I didn't know what
that
meant except that I knew that I was
relying on all of this external
stimulation to build an identity that I
really wasn't and then I had to show up
for people and look a certain way and
act a certain way and that that wasn't
me and it got disturbing for me and I
had this gap between the way I appeared
and the way I really was and I didn't
make time for myself and make time to be
the example I mean my motive has always
be the example of everything that I
teach if I'm not I'm not I shouldn't be
up here uh I shouldn't be leading in my
clinic if I if I don't live those
principles myself if I don't live my
life that way and and so um you know and
the at the height of uh my popularity I
disappeared I canceled all my events my
friends thought I was on crack or
something they thought I lost my mind
cuz you know what they were saying you
could make so much money and I said I
don't really I know how to make money I
really don't care about money I really
don't I care about how happy I'm going
to be with
myself and I broke from the world for 6
months and
retreated and I really decided that if I
presented myself back to the world that
I wasn't going to be seduced by it in
the same way that I really wanted to be
the example of everything that I taught
and I wanted to lead events in a way
that empowered people I never wanted it
to be about me I wanted it to be about
you rule number four is Embrace change
the concept of transformation is a
really important message and and we use
meditation as the mechanism because I
want people to become so familiar with
their old personality self that they
don't default anymore and keep
reaffirming that new person it's so much
easier to forget that Vision than to
remember it so you got to constantly
remind yourself reproduce the same level
of mind you got to constantly
emotionally embrace it keep conditioning
the body the thought and the feeling the
image and the emotion the stimulus and
response you're conditioning your body
into the future instead of waking up
every morning and remembering your
problems and those problems are
associated with people and object of
things at certain times and places and
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with so people are
remembering their past they're feeling
the emotions they're firing and wiring
the same circuits and feeling the same
OT they're conditioning their body into
the past and that's why changes so hard
because the moment you step out from
doing the same thing and making a
different choice there's going to be
some discomfort cuz the body
subconsciously has been programmed
emotionally into the past so the the
moment you make a different Choice
you're stepping out of the known into
the unknown the body starts influencing
the mind to return back to the familiar
place that's why people have difficulty
changing and yet if meditation is the
model to become so familiar with your
old self and so familiar with your new
self how many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment called
change okay give people the tools and
let them practice and they'll actually
start enjoying it okay but if you're not
being defined by a vision of the
future uh I assert you're left with the
memories of the past and you'll be
predictable in your life so you wake up
in the morning you see your coworker you
see your husband you see you're on a
zoom call you're picking up your cell
phone for most people it's the
environment it's actually causing them
to think and feel equal to everything
that they know so it's not their
personality that's creating their
personal reality it's their personal
reality that's reaffirming their
personality it's their environment
that's controlling the way they feel and
the way they think why because every
person your husband your co-workers your
your
employees your dog your cell phone every
one of those things you have a
neurological Network that you've
actually created because you've
experienced them and because you've
experienced them you have an emotion
associated with them so if we're not
being defined by a vision of the future
when we see the same people we go to the
same places and we do the exact same
thing at the exact same time the
environment is controlling the way we
feel and the way we think but if how we
think and how we feel actually creates
our life as long as we're thinking equal
to everything that we know everything
stays the same because nothing changes
in our life until we change okay so the
conditioning process the thought and the
feeling the memory and the emotion
you're thinking in the past when you
remember your problems you feel the
emotion associated with it you're you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind of that emotion and it's so
objective it's believing it's living the
same past experience 24 hours a day 7
days a week 365 days a year and now
you're headed in a very specific genetic
outcome okay you get up you get up in
the morning you do the same thing as you
did yesterday you go through this whole
routine and you keep doing that your
body's on autopilot now and habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through repetition habit is
when you've done something so many times
the body actually knows now how to do it
better than your conscious mind that
means your body is the mind that's
dragging you into that predictable
future based on what you did in the past
and you lost your free will to a set of
programs and rule number five the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is don't live in survival mode now
what's your environment made of objects
things places body people right so it's
very material okay so now right the
arousal causes us to pay more attention
to the outer world and less attention to
our inner world and this Rush of
chemicals causes us to become very
preoccupied with trying to make that
feeling of survival and stress go away
so time becomes very relevant as well so
now your body is where you put your
attention your environment is where you
put your attention and your attention is
on time well it turns out to change is
actually to be great greater than your
body to be greater than your environment
and be greater than time so if people
are spending the majority of their life
with the emergency system switched on
it's not a time to create it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to go
within it's not a time to meditate it
goes against the survival Gene that says
you will be prey it's not a time to open
your heart it's not a time to commune
it's not even a time to eat look at the
last few years yeah so people spend
their majority of their time shutting uh
let me say it another way so then so
then when a person is living in survival
and they're trying to control and
predict and change everything that's
going on in their life every person that
they know every object or thing that
they own every place that they know or
have lived or
go-to and everything they've experienced
in their past they're going to try to
predict in their future so now the
arousal of stress hormones causes the
brain to fire out of order because every
person every object everything has a
different neurological Network in the
brain now the brain is firing
incoherently and when it's firing
incoherently we're incoherent at the
same time you're sitting in a zoom
meeting and it's not T-Rex it's your
coworker and you're actually producing
the same chemicals as if you're being
chased by T-Rex but you don't you're not
running you're not fighting you're not
hiding you're doing sitting there and
those the chemicals are running through
the body and the heart is actually
pumping really hard because it's turned
on and it's got a run fight hide and
you're sitting there and the heart is
actually pumping against the closed
system and the Heart starts to become
incoherent and when incoherence takes
place in the heart the interference of
of waves actually causes energy to drop
in the heart so now you have no energy
in the heart you have no energy in the
brain and now the person is living in
their animal self in that animal nature
right and so they're waiting for
something to change in their outer world
they're waiting for something to change
in their outer world to take away this
feeling of fear or anxiety or
frustration or impatience or resentment
or pain or suffering or guilt or shame
and they're living by that emotional
state and they would rather
cling to those memories and those
emotions because at least it's the known
right and it's
survival why because in survival the
unknown you better run from the unknown
there's better chances of survival so
nobody takes a chance right okay so so
then back to the 3D World then the
Newtonian world the classical world of
quantum physics is all about Newtonian
physics is all about the predictable
right we can shoot a rocket to the moon
if we know the distance and the speed of
the rocket we can determine the time
it's going to take to get there so this
three-dimensional reality is all about
predictions right okay well you can get
what you want but you got to work really
hard and it's going to take a lot of
time and energy you can develop the
skills to get it okay now so
is there possibly another way to do it I
mean okay let's look at another way is
there another way to
actually do it in a shorter amount of
time to shorten the distance between the
thought of what you want and the
experience of having it between the
cause and the effect from one point of
Consciousness uh I'm here and another
point of Consciousness I want the
experience of this here is there a way
to do that okay well let's unpack the
whole model of quantum
physics okay so you look at an adom an
Adam is 99999 99% nothing and I say
nothing I mean it's energy it's nothing
it's a
0.00001% physical and material and it is
a sci yeah that's where we're made of
and it's a scientific fact it's the the
mathematics prove that we're perceiving
less than 1% of reality okay so what
we're perceiving then is the frequency
of light the wavelength of light coming
off the sun which is the the rainbow
bouncing off of objects that give us the
illusion of Separation in
three-dimensional reality okay that's
that's what all we're seeing right we're
seeing and experiencing the material
world by light being being projected
onto it take away the light out of
threedimensional reality um you don't
really have a whole lot of experience of
it you bump into a lot of things I mean
take away all light okay so so the the
the atom is both particle
material and wave and what's wave what
is wave frequency what is frequency
energy what does frequency and energy do
they carry information okay so the
quantum field then is that invisible
field of energy of frequency that exists
beyond our senses that we're not
perceiving but it still exists just
because we're unaware of it doesn't mean
it doesn't exist okay so how much of
your waking day in your Waking Life do
you put your attention on matter
and how much of your waking day do you
put your attention on frequency and
energy well throw in the hormones of
stress and your attentions on your body
on the environment and time where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so now all of your energy
and attention is is invested in this
three dimensional reality and it appears
really real cuz that's where our
attention
is believe in the thought I can't
meditate or I don't have enough time or
I'm a really important person or I got
too many too many emails the answer or
AG day or it's my mother's fault it's my
ex's fault I want to complain I want to
blame I want to make excuses I want to
lay down my bladder's full I like this
what am I doing wrong they're agitated
impatient
that's that's the personality that has
been
hardwired and conditioned emotionally
into the past that's resisting the
unknown it would rather cling to
suffering then take a chance in
possibilities so our events we say okay
here's the knowledge and I can say now
with a great degree of certainty more
than ever MH that if you actually do
this and you stretch yourself a little
bit
further than where you would normally go
at home your brain will change and if
you teach people how to do this over and
over again and no
different than training an animal the
body is the animal are you training the
body that you're in charge is that what
you do you're telling the body it's no
longer the mind that you're the mind yes
and when you do that those victories add
up and then all of a sudden there's a
liberation of
energy there goes the guilt there goes
the pain there goes the whatever it
doesn't matter if it's Health it doesn't
matter if it's wealth or success it
doesn't matter if it's a a loving
relationship a change in a career a
mystical experience whatever it is the
person all of a sudden starts to relax
into the present moment I think we're
reality producing machines I mean
there's no there's no single individ
idual on this planet who doesn't create
reality unless they have a brain injury
or something but for the most part most
of us are engaged in reality you know
and we do cause effects I think we reach
a certain point in our life where we
stop learning and we start feeling and
when we use feelings as a barometer for
the
unknown it's a it's it's contraindicated
because feelings are usually a record of
a past experience so we try to predict
how that future event is going to be
based on a Feeling and we always return
back to the old self again so I love the
idea of how we can actually produce
effects I love the idea that every human
being is either lives in one of two
states of mind we either live in
creation which is growth and expansion
and and it's um health and homeostasis
the emotions of love and joy and Trust
make us feel connected to something
bigger than us or we live in a state of
survival and a state of survival is
living living in stress and living in
stress is when your body is knocked out
of balance and the redundancy of that
cycle over time that imbalance that
keeps happening begins to break the body
down and and I think the biggest problem
for us because of the size of our brains
is we can turn on the stress response
just by thought alone and we do it all
day long in that continuous
redundant being out of balance over time
that inbalance becomes the new balance
and now we're headed for contraction and
disease and feeling separate from the
field and being selfish instead of
selfless we begin to um live in a state
of breakdown in a state of um uh um uh
uh disease and and a lack of health and
and so then those emotions then of those
survival chemicals endorse the ego and
then we become more self-indulgent and
more self-important and more selfs
serving uh because that's what those
chemicals do so we live in one of those
two states of mind now those chemicals
tend to be highly addictive so this is
really good dinner conversation we can
talk about it right but actually
breaking through that's I think when you
free yourself from the chains of those
emotions that that that we memorize when
we actually break through and when we
remove that mind out of the body when we
break the emotion that's trapped
in physical flesh and the body's
liberated that's true self-love that's
true Joy it's the liberation of energy
so the anger that once was in there the
hatred that was once in there the
Prejudice that was once in there is
transformed it's transmuted into joy and
it's the same energy but it just has a
different
Spin and so no one can do that for you
you know that that isn't something where
someone you know waves a wand and then
it happens you have to actually be
willing to be on
comfortable as you break that addiction
and be okay with it and then the moment
the body's liberated and you feel that
expansion that's the natural state of
being now you say I love myself so much
because I went further than I thought I
could go I transcended some limitation
about myself in the way I think in the
way I act in the way I feel that's the
personality that's the identity changing
one of those
things really changing it not just like
changing your mind like I want vanilla
ice cream instead of chocolate ice cream
but truly changing something that
changes your NE neurology or neuros
circuitry changes the chemistry which is
your emotions that signal the gene that
begins to change your very expression of
health and a very expression of
life talking about when you make that
emphatic you know declaration where you
make that
change and it's
undeniable there's a
biological neurological and Quantum
effect as a result of it well I think I
flirt primarily with the idea of how
subjective mind has an effect on the
objective world you know Newtonian
physics is about cause and effect it's
about something outside of you
fundamentally changing something inside
of you you know we are an expression or
a reflection of the environment so as
long as the environment is influencing
how we're thinking and feeling we can
only be as great as the environment so
and if we're thinking and feeling equal
to the environment we could only create
more of the same environment you know
the idea that we can change something
inside of us in our in our Consciousness
in our thoughts and in our
feelings and be able to memorize both
neurologically and our brain and
hardwire that information install
hardware and condition the body
emotionally to be a mind so mind and
body are working together if we're able
to maintain that modified state of being
then there should be some evidence
outside of us so instead of cause and
effect I always love the idea of causing
effects and to cause an effect so the
quantum model says you can cause an
effect and so I think where we get stuck
with that is the idea that you know that
it has to be predictable that we should
be able to know how it's going to happen
and and that is that is I think our
biggest error because we can never
control the outcome of the unpredictable
that's the quantum model it has to be
uncertain it has to come in a way that
we least expect that surprises us that
that leaves no doubt that what we did
inside of us produced some effect
outside of us and and when you begin to
have those small synchronicities at
first and then they turn into larger and
larger events and you experience that
that awe and that Wonder or that joy and
appreciation for being alive I I think
that's the natural state of being I
think that's having that kind of
sensibility coming from within us
instead of needing something outside of
us to change our state in a sense then
it's not the personality that chooses
the body or the parents or it's the soul
that chooses it does that make sense yes
but if a person gets caught in routine
and gets lost in the Quagmire of life
then the ego takes over and the soul is
diminished and now the person is doing
their best to become a somebody a
someone own something be somewhere in
some time and of course if that's the
journey and the person's not willing to
find wisdom or look for truth then they
can play on that level for as long as
they want until they're tired of it and
when they finally get bored with it and
they'll they'll want to choose something
else and Eternity is a long time
wouldn't you
agree so then the Soul then says okay
here's the options probable lines of
time there are probable lines of time
that are the more probable than others
and there is a probable line of time for
living in the same body and raising your
frequency to the point where you can go
wherever you want with your body that's
the ultimate yes or no and you can whip
bread out of nothing and you can be in
two places at once and you can be on the
the uh an alternate universe and have a
whole life there and you can be
dimensional that's that's the freedom of
when you've mastered yourself and you've
mastered the conditions but most of
us are headed in a certain timeline
based on our genes and based on our own
personal Evolution and that's what makes
this time right now so powerful this
time right now is the age of
information and in an age of information
ignorance is actually a choice and
people are beginning to realize I don't
need a doctor to find out what my
disease is I don't need to go to the
library or talk to my teacher I can just
I can just find the information and
people are starting to wake up to
Greater understandings and that is
starting to become the collective and
that Collective energy in the field the
collective Consciousness the collective
awareness is changing the future of
humanity yes or no and at the same
time the past is
crumbling there is economic collapse
there's political collapse there's
religious collapse there's environmental
collapse there's there's all of that is
breaking down journalistic collapse I
who watches the news and expects to hear
the truth I mean it's just all falling
apart and it's becoming so obvious to
people that all of a sudden they're
realizing that the people that run the
world or people that are in places of
Power are actually really really worse
off than you and I and the only thing
that has to happen is that we have to
collectively become one mind
and when we collectively become one mind
we no longer are seduced by those things
and we are now like a flock of birds all
moving in the same direction and those
fish all of a sudden moving as a
school nobody's leading everybody's
leading we're just connected and what do
you think we're doing when you tune in
to the power of love in this room don't
you know everybody dialing into that
same frequency is causing that frequency
to be in this room and if everybody's
doing it it's getting more conf ated
more coherent more organized and if you
put your attention on it there's more of
it so then when you're leading with your
heart that's enough that's enough so
then when you have a collective mind and
people are moving in that way and
they're no longer reacting to politics
or whatever and they no longer need
those things you're catching somebody
who's starting to awaken yes or no and
if you're focusing on the Divine and
that's where all of your attention is
you won't see ethnicity
you won't see skin color you won't see
anything as separation you'll just be
like wow nice costume to the masquerade
I should have wore
that it's crazy because then people go
get their genetics found out and you
know some of them you know just really
have an intolerance to some culture and
they're 40% of that
culture
so what makes this time for me so unique
and I'm speaking
personally is that there's such a
quickening going on more things are
happening in a shorter amount of time
would you agree and if more things are
happening in a shorter amount of time it
becomes more difficult to predict the
next moment this point we're reaching
this noal point is the point of in
unpredictability and the old is
collapsing and the collapsing of the old
should never be faced with with fear
with bigotry with with with anger with
hostility with guilt sadness and shame
cuz that's how we've been controlled all
along and by the way I mean I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but if you want to
control people manipulate their emotions
so as we move closer and closer to that
point the probability of US changing our
life the length of our life not from low
stress foods and not from vitamins all
those things are good matter to
matter but stress is going to
downregulate the gene consume the body's
energy and now that's going to begin to
Signal the gene to produce the disease
that the person has inherited in the
first place are you with me still so
when you react to someone or something
and you're living by the same emotional
state you keep the same genes on the
same genes off and that's your genetic
Destiny and now the Awakening of this
even
if even if we Chang little timelines
just this week we Chang lines of time
you change something about yourself you
are going to walk into a different
future that is your genetic timeline and
now you're bumped off course you just
got to be willing to stay in the unknown
and be comfortable with it and that's
when you're at your greatest if people
are not aware how can they become aware
and once they become aware what sort of
things should they start to do to start
making those
changes yeah thank you for for teasing
that out that's such a great question
you know
um uh my interest is to give people the
tools so that they have within their
reach all the things they need to begin
to apply and become scientists in their
life people don't know if you don't know
that those stress hormones are addictive
then you think they have power over you
if you don't think that you can change
your thought just because you have a a
thought it doesn't necessarily mean it's
true and when the moment I realized that
I was free right and if you isolate
yourself a lot and you don't you're not
out in the world because of whatever
you'll you'll you'll you'll start to
believe every thought that you think is
the truth and so that challenge then of
saying
okay I do truly want to be happy I do
truly want to be healthy I do truly want
to have a life that that is empowering
that I feel good about okay well let's
take a look like if no different than
well you use the example of Tiger Woods
no different than Tiger Woods watching
himself swing on a video observing
himself play no different than a person
who stands in front of an audience and
does a lecture and watches them do the
lecture nobody else will see what they
see they'll see themselves very
differently than anybody else and
they'll they'll see themselves do it and
they'll want to self-correct they'll
want to evolve their experience now
because we got this big frontal loob 40%
of our entire brain that's our
conscience that's a seat of our
awareness that's our creative Center
when we ask the question what would it
be like to be in a different life or to
be happy if instead of getting on your
cell phone or instead of getting on your
social media or instead of turning on
the TV or instead of calling a friend
and instead of doing something to
distract you from
that possible answer if you sat with it
long enough and that creative Center
turned on it would naturally scan the
whole entire landscape of the brain
because it's the CEO it's the symphony
leader has connections to all parts of
the brain and it's going to look out
over the landscape of the brain and look
at the knowledge you've learned and the
experiences that are stitched in your
brain that are associated with what you
know to answer that question and as it
calls up these different networks of
neurons once the brain fires in tandem
you get an image or a picture in your
mind and that's called intention you see
a new possibility right so
then this is why I am passionate about
what we're doing I never thought rengan
that I would see the kind of changes in
people's physical health that I've seen
in the last two years now people do the
best with what they think is available
if you don't know that this is possible
you are going to make the same choice
and that may be relying on some
pharmaceutical something outside of you
some therapy whatever there's nothing
wrong with
that but if your response hasn't changed
in your life the efficacy of whatever
you're doing is going to be diminished
okay so once I now know that people
could heal from different health
conditions and there's evidence in the
science and there's evidence in
testimony like the person that you just
recited that's one of many many people
that have had that experience when they
stand on the stage at our week-long
Retreats and we call them up why do I
call them up on the stage because they
are speaking the truth they are the
example of Truth and I want people to
become aware of that possibility why
because if you're unaware of it it
doesn't exist for you Consciousness is
awareness right and so then with
Consciousness you can't have
Consciousness without energy so there
that that thought thought of another
possibility is a different energy it's a
different possibility and and so now
once you know it's possible then okay
now let's get down to stepping in the
footprints that other people have left
behind why if you're telling the story
of your past every single day and 50% of
that isn't even the truth then you're
reliving a miserable life you never even
had all for the reason to excuse
yourself from change stop telling the
story of your past and start telling the
story of your future stop Romancing your
past and start Romancing your future why
not fall in love with your future as
much as you've fallen in love with your
past how many people in this
audience actually believe in the idea
that the way you think has some effect
on your life that your thoughts create
your life you believe that
yes so how how many people here actually
woke up this morning and consciously
created a
future you know the biggest reason why
people don't do
it is because you don't really believe
it's
true you see if you knew on a gut level
that it was absolutely
true would you ever miss a day come on
and would you ever let any thought slip
by your awareness that you didn't want
to
experience so your brain according to
Neuroscience is organized to reflect
everything you know in your life your
brain is a record of your environment
it's a record an artifact of your
past so if you believe this then then
does your environment control your
thinking or does your thinking control
your environment
so if you wake up in the morning and you
get out of bed on the same exact side as
you did the day before you shut the
alarm clock off with the same finger you
slip into your favorite slippers you
Shuffle into the bathroom and you use
the toilet like you always do then you
walk over to the mirror and you look at
yourself to remember who you
are then you get into the shower and you
wash yourself in the same routine way
then you groom yourself to look like
everybody expects you to
look then you go downstairs and you
drink coffee out of your favorite mug
then you drive the work the same way as
you did the day before you see the same
people that push the same emotional
buttons you do the exact thing that you
know how to do and you memorize and can
do so well that you're an expert at then
you hurry up and rush home so you can
hurry up and check your emails so you
could hurry up and go to bed so you can
hurry up and do it all over again
now here's my question did your brain
change at all that day we could say that
you were thinking the same thoughts
performing the same actions that create
the same experiences that produce the
same emotions but secretly expecting
something to change in your life would
you
agree so then as the environment turns
on different circuits in your brain you
begin to think equal to your environment
as you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the same things at
the same time it's the external
environment that's turning on different
circuits in your brain causing you to
think equal to everything that you know
and as long as you think equal to
everything that's familiar and known to
you what do you keep creating more of
same same life now the quantum law is
still applying to you you're just
thinking equal to everything that you
know and you keep creating more of the
same to change to truly change is to
think think greater than your
environment and every great person in
history knew this whether it was William
Wallace or mahat mandhi or Martin Luther
King or Queen Elizabeth the first or
Joan of Arc they all had a vision they
all had an idea couldn't see it couldn't
smell it couldn't taste it couldn't feel
it but it was alive in their
mind it was so alive in their mind that
they began to live as if that reality
was actually happening
now so can you believe in a future
future that you can't see or experience
with your senses yet but you've thought
about enough times in your mind that
your brain is literally changed to look
like the event has already happened
Neuroscience says it's absolutely
possible you got to go out into life and
try it out okay I've changed my internal
State you could have a great meditation
you can connect your heart could open
this happened to me you could open your
heart You' be amazing you feel like the
day is invincible and you get up and
then the rest of your day you're
unconscious the 15 hours of your day so
you're going to weigh 1 hour of being in
a different state of being against 15
hours of you being unhappy and rushing
and in a program so then how many
times do we have to forget until we stop
forgetting and start remembering that's
called change how many times do we have
to go
unconscious to the point where we no
longer go unconscious and we stay
conscious that's the moment of change
now if you're truly out of the bleachers
and you're on the playing field and this
happens to a lot of people in our work
they say you know I really believe that
this is the truth I really believe that
you could heal yourself I really believe
you could change your life I've seen the
testimonials I just never believed that
it could happen to me now this is a big
moment now you're really stepping on the
playing field so a person who starts
doing their work they're not they're not
interested in healing the true the
person who's truly interested in this
work they understand that the only way
they can heal is that they have to
change they're not saying I'm going to
wait for my wealth or my healing to
happen in order for me to feel grateful
and be joyful in life they're saying if
I feel grateful my healing is going to
begin right if I if I'm feel more whole
then there should be some change in my
gene expression so they've studied the
content they've studied the information
and now it becomes EXT extremely
practical so they may have a great
meditation and we've seen this happen to
many people they sleep better they have
less pain they have more energy but
their blood values never change now they
don't say oh I feel better but I'm
failing this doesn't work they say what
is it about me that's stopping this from
completely healing okay how am
I in my waking day the moment you begin
to ask that question you turn on the
frontal lobe and the frontal lobe is the
seat of your conscience now the moment
you start looking at at the end of your
day how did I do this is such an
important question how' I do today did I
fall from grace when did I lose it and
who did I lose it with if I had another
opportunity how would I do it
differently they'll tell you I've I've
seen them stand on the stage and tell
their story and say I had to start
really watching myself in my life yeah
how I was emotionally responding to my
ex how I was emotionally responding to
my financial problems I had to really
really pay attention that and that takes
an enormous amount of energy and an
enormous amount of awareness to stop the
program right so you forget and you go
damn I went unconscious there now you
didn't lose you didn't fail you just
became conscious now if you keep
becoming so conscious of your
unconscious States you're you're outside
the program you're only in the program
when you're unconscious the moment
you're conscious you can objectify your
subjective self so you can see yourself
Through The Eyes of someone else so the
learning process comes from the mistake
the brain learns by mistakes and
surprises I I've made enough of them in
my life it's just whether you're going
to do it again you want to do it again
you're back in the habit back in the
routine if you say this is it the next
time that happens I am not going to do
that not for anybody else but because
those
emotions actually my response to that
person or that circumstance is actually
weakening the organ
is that that circum worth it so then
it's Evolution it's Evolution the
challenge then has to be met with a
greater level of mind now if you're just
doing your meditation just because you
want to please God or do the right thing
or feel good about yourself that's going
to get stale after a while because it's
just going to become another routine
between your coffee and your shower and
your emails and your drive to work and
people aren't present right so so the
familiar past condition is based on the
past that thought and the feeling but
habituation is the programming into
predictable future that's the known so
if you teach a person how to find the
present moment that's where the unknown
exists and that takes that takes a lot
of energy and a lot of awareness and yet
if you practice it the body literally
will begin to respond to the mind it's
like training an animal it finally
relaxes and when that occurs your
response to people and circumstances in
your life will be different because you
overcame yourself at the beginning of
the day I believe that your personality
creates your personal
reality and uh in order to change your
personal reality your life it means then
that on some level we have to change
because nothing changes in our life
unless we
change so if people have understand that
90% of the thoughts that they think
every day are the same thoughts as the
day
before that's that's a fact and the same
thoughts always lead to the same choice
es the same choices always lead to the
same behaviors the same behaviors create
the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce the very same feelings and
emotions and those same emotions
influence our very same thoughts and our
biology or neur circuitry or neoch
chemistry or hormones or Gene
Expressions stays the same because we're
the same but the repetition of firing
and wiring the same circuits in our
brain in the same way uh causes us to uh
create a very finite set of circuitry
that becomes our identity and our
personality and nerve cells that fire
together wire together which means you
keep doing it it gets easier for them to
fire and they run more
automatically so turns out 95% of Who We
Are by our midlife is a set of memorized
uh behaviors unconscious habits
hardwired thoughts and attitudes uh
conditioned emotions that are so
familiar to us that it doesn't even feel
like uh uh fear or it doesn't feel like
sadness it's just who we are so it
usually takes crisis or trauma or
disease or diagnosis or your lowest
point in your life where you're knocked
to your
knees and for that moment you actually
have a view of yourself outside of
yourself you can see yourself uh from a
different state the the facade the the
the the the whole illusion is over and
that's when a person really begins to
think about what what they've been
thinking about they begin to notice how
they speak or how they act and I think
they begin to pay attention to those
feelings uh on a on a more uh regular
and conscious basis and the word
meditation I look this up because when I
started my journey I'm I'm I'm
very uh scientifically minded the word
meditation the symbol means to become
familiar with
so so then the first step to change if
you wanted to create a new life you have
to change uh uh to change your personal
reality you have to change your
personality and the first step is
consciousness or becoming aware so the
moment you become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts the moment you
become aware of your automatic reflexive
habits and and your emotional reactions
the moment you can become so conscious
of those unconscious states of Mind and
Body uh that you don't go unconscious
again so familiar with those States and
how many times do we have to forget or
go unconscious till we no longer forget
or go unconscious and we stay conscious
that's that's that's s that's lighting a
match in a dark place and most people
when they do meditation they they
actually think when those voices come up
and when the chatter starts and those
emotions start they actually think that
they're doing their meditation
wrong and I want them to know that
they're actually doing it right because
you're coming up against those thoughts
that slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by many people uh you all of a
sudden catch how you speak and people
say if I really want to be happy let's
think about this I don't want to I don't
want to complain I don't want to blame I
don't want to make excuses I don't want
to feel sorry for myself I'm going to
stop that now that's breaking a habit of
being yourself that's a that takes a lot
of energy and a lot of awareness and and
and our environment then the
circumstances our environment are oh
always available for us to think and
feel equal to everything in our life you
know so the environment for many people
as we said earlier controls the way they
think and feel so when they respond to
their coworker when they respond to the
news when they respond to the um the the
traffic in their life uh that response
causes them to return back to those
unconscious programs so but sitting in a
meditation and really sitting in the
fire
and believing that there something on
the other side of that thought uh uh
believing that there's something on the
other side of some Behavior or some
emotion uh that feel makes us feel a
certain way that's that's stepping into
the unknown and and it takes um it takes
us disconnecting from the environment
that's what meditation is about playing
music or hearing nothing or closing your
eyes and not eating not smelling not
tasting not feeling with your body
you're putting your body away and you're
not letting it be the mind or the
program you're making it sit still
you're training the animal right and and
a person starts feeling emotional and
they catch
themselves starting to feel those
emotions instead of letting that emotion
Drive certain thoughts or actions that
person settles the body down uh in the
meditation and brings it back into the
present moment and that's a victory if
you study the Neuroscience of culture
you know it's so so unique because we
have we share the same biology we share
the same brain and because we share the
same biology and the same brain we we
have certain Universal traits that are
that are unique to human beings we smile
and we're happy we frown and we're sad
we sleep at night for the most part we
grab a stick with an opposing thumb so
structure and function are highly
related and those are Universal traits
and then we have our individual traits
and that's kind of like how the brain is
wired right that it's like our
fingerprint as opposed to our hand right
so we have an individual series of
traits and that make us unique and we
have our Universal traits but what
Bridges the universality of us and
commonality as human beings with our
individuality and that's culture and
culture really is defined for the most
part by the past what has worked over
Generations or Traditions that have
sustained the culture based on one thing
and that one thing is en environment so
a culture in Northern Mongolia is
certainly different than a culture in
Central Mex Mexico because it's a
different environment and those
different Customs that are created from
that environment allow that culture to
sustain itself so look at look at great
people in history that that changed the
culture whether it was Gandhi whether it
was William Wallace whether it was Joon
of Arc whether it was Martin Luther King
whoever it was that changed the
culture what they did really well is
they showed people that there was an
alternative future that they could
actually believe or perceive in their
mind
now you can't see that future if you're
living by the same emotions of the past
and for most people they live by the
emotions of the past what you have to do
is you got to get people out of their
resting state they have to become
inspired they have to become
enthusiastic in Theos filled with God
they have to become uh motivated in some
way they have to be moved uh and when
they are moved emotionally then that
that that energy that emotion causes
them to see the same future as that
leader sees and you when you get people
seeing that same future and they have
that clear intention and you combine
that with a different emotion you're
changing people's state of being now get
enough people doing that and what what
happens is you get an emergent
Consciousness emergence in biology is
such a phenomenal thing because when you
see a group of birds or a flock of birds
flying in the same direction or a school
of fish moving together they appear as a
larger organism when you study that
principle in biology you think that
there's a leader that everybody's
following that it's a top- down
phenomenon in fact it's not it's a
bottomup phenomenon and everybody's
leaving leading everybody's behaving in
the same way and the appearance of a
larger organism becomes more sustainable
for that species
so we have such a stigma in our minds
that if you lead with too much passion
you're going to get it in the end
whether your Jesus Christ or Abraham
Lincoln or uh William WS whoever it was
the the outcome for truth is usually you
lose your life but the real question is
what if everybody's
leading and you just can't take out
everybody now so so this is a really
important time because the emergent
Consciousness that has to take place has
to be built on principles and the
principles that people can actually wrap
their mind around they have to keep
their mind on it for a period of time
where they're not distracted by
technology they're not distracted by
Tick Tock and they're not distracted by
social media and they're not distracted
by the news that that that the the
eminent condition of the world right now
and the way things are going based on
self-interests are all based on survival
and you can control people when you
control their emotions and when you
control their emotions you control their
attention and if you can capture a
person's attention you can capture their
energy because where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and so you could actually program people
to do
anything based on the emotion that they
feel and fear is a great emotion to
cause people to rely on some authorative
figure to lead them away so if there's a
new Consciousness that emerges that that
is based on not fruits and nuts and not
uh you know not on crystals not on
colonics uh uh not on any of those
things but this is game time this is
where something else has to be born in
human beings that is already innate in
us uh and that is the power to organize
as a species uh when we begin to heal
one another when we begin to inform one
another when we begin to respect one
another when we begin to shine for one
another when we begin to stand up for
one another when we begin to abilities
and then
demonst people that there are other ways
of doing thing and share that right
information I think an emerging
Consciousness will actually take place
and God I think this is the time in
history more than ever uh where where it
matters the most when people first thing
they have to do is they have to overcome
their survival States they have to over
overcome their programs they're going to
be willing to sit with themselves long
enough to wonder what's on the other
side of I can't or it's too hard or I
want to give up or this sucks what's on
the other side side of those thoughts
those are just programmed thoughts
what's on the other side of this emotion
called guilt or this emotion called
frustration what's on the other side of
it right so you get people to a certain
point you give them uh a little bit of
help but the key then is we've done
we've done studies on this if you close
your eyes and you place your attention
on your heart turns out where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy right so if you can put your
attention on your heart and not your
cell phone and you can keep it on your
heart and feel it and experience it and
pay attention to it by paying attention
to your heart you're actually giving it
your energy now your heart tends to feel
different emotions uh than other parts
of your body and what emotions it loves
to feel is love Compassion Care kindness
gratitude inspiration Freedom these are
elevated emotions so if you could put
your attention on your heart we see from
the technology that we built in time and
not a very long amount of time just a
few minutes you'll start to see this
very low frequency of the heart start
going up which means the the energy
that's indigenous to the heart with the
heart uses only you're actually feeding
it it's it energy right so if you could
do that then and then you can slow your
breathing down when you slow your
breathing down you slow your brain waves
down we've measured that thousands of
times so instead of the short breath or
this instead of this kind of shallow
breath you only work on taking long slow
breaths through your heart inhale with
the intention of relaxing hold it with
the intention of relaxing while you hold
it exhale with the intention of relaxing
blow all the air out hold it for a few
seconds you're not going to die relax
again inhale again and just do a series
of three or four or five or six of these
depending on working with your body so
that it starts to feel safe again that's
what it is it slow your brain wavs down
you slow your breathing down you slow
your breathing down you convert from the
sympathetic to the parasympathetic and
that's what we see then all a sudden we
see the person's parasympathetic
nervosismo up and sympathetic goes down
what does that mean they're at moving
out of stress okay the body is moving
into that state of growth and repair now
put your attention on your heart now do
something really cool amplify that's the
amplifier that's the creative Center so
what do you want to feel like what
emotion do you want to feel when a
future experience happens whatever that
is feel the Gratitude feel the joy feel
the freedom and breathe and feel and
feel and breathe and keep relaxing into
your heart keeping your attention
nowhere else out of the millions of
things you can put your attention on
that's your Target and you work with
your body and you breathe and you feel
and as you start relaxing into your
heart you keep working on relaxing into
your heart and you feel it you feel that
emotion there'll come a moment where
that energy will naturally start moving
up to the brain and when that
happens the survival centers shut down
brain moves into Alpha you see more in
pictures and images you could take it's
like a taking a sheet of paper uh a
sheet on a on on a bed and going like
this the heart sends is propagating wave
right into the brain just it follows
boom right after the stroke volume and
it's telling the brain to be creative to
dream to be you know to be unlimited uh
so the more you do that here's the
key the more you do it the more it
becomes a skill
now when a person has a panic attack
right what they do is they mismanage
their attention they they picture the
worst scenario that could possibly take
place and then they say no what if this
happens what if this happen what if this
happens they're making it actually 10
times worse because if you prepare for
the worst there's always better chances
of survival the problem is they're
combining that image in their mind and
they're actually living the experience
emotionally and so they're taking that
thought and that feeling that image and
that emotion that stimulus and response
and they're conditioning the body
subconsciously to become the mind of
fear after a certain point when the body
is that out of balance it will have a
panic attack try as you may to control
it with your conscious mind you can't
you programed it subconsciously then it
gets worse because after that one you
can't anticipate when the next one's
going to happen so you start getting
ready for the next one and that's what
exactly starts the cycle okay so what we
discovered that the more you relax into
your heart and feel these elevated
emotions it's exactly like a panic
attack only it's a love attack we have
such great evidence to show that there's
something very profound that
happens when a person has a
transcendental moment and they have an
interaction with energy when they hit
those elegant
States they sometimes come to events as
sick we draw their blood at the
beginning of their event their event and
they we see their what happens to to
their brain we see what happens to their
heart and we know this person has had a
profound moment and we draw their blood
and we measure everything
afterwards if we take the plasma of
those
individuals as an example and we take a
pseudo virus that looks just like SARS
K2 or we actually take now recently we
actually did the actual SARS virus and
we put that
virus in the presence of that person
that meditator that had that
transcendental
moment there is a consistent resistance
to the virus the virus cannot enter the
cell of that person in people that are
novice meditators and they come to a
weekl long event some of the virus
enters their cell and some of the virus
stays out so there's somewhat of an
immunity in all the controls they get
infected all right so we know now that
there's some agent some co-actor in the
the blood when a person has this moment
so we've gone through extensive
scientific studies and we actually
isolated the very
protein that stops the virus from
entering the cell and if we take that
protein and we put it in the infected
plasma of the
controls all of the infected controls
become
uninfected now we're not getting that
from anywhere out there we're actually
finding it in
someone who has had a moment where
they've interacted with Oneness with
wholeness and whether it's there's some
change in energy in the blood and
there's some proteins being released but
we're starting to discover there's some
powerful agents when this occurs take
the blood of that advanced meditator and
put it take their plasma and put it in a
uterine cancer cell and and the cancer
cells the mitochondria the powerhouses
of the cells are switched on and they're
pumping out a lot of energy that's why
they're almost Immortal if we take the
blood of the advanced meditator and we
subject to a uterine cancer cell 75% of
the energy comes out of the mitochondria
takes the wind out of the
cells take the plasma of that the same
Advanced
meditator and put it on a neuron that
has Alzheimer's and produces the amalo
protein and there's a significant change
in the gene expression of the Alzheimer
Gene take that person then and subject
their blood to the
variant the Lambda variant the Delta
variant the beta variant and the same
thing occurs they're
resistant uh to the virus now what does
that mean
okay if you really think about
this it would
suggest that there's very dramatic
environmental changes taking place from
a scientific standpoint anybody who sees
this kind of gene expression change or
change in biology they would say oh my
God that suggests that there's a
dramatic change in the environment the
problem is is the person is sitting in a
ballroom in a hotel there's not a lot
lot of things going on in a ballroom in
a hotel it's not a changing environment
where is all that change coming from
information from the field so we have
great great testimony in our community
of people that have reversed all kinds
of things and people have created all
kinds of wealth and created all kinds of
mystical moments and we have really
great evidence in our scientific studies
and evidence is the loudest voice it is
the voice that makes the biggest
difference so what kind of human being
then who has trained themselves
to no longer be victim to their
environment if I said to you amilio why
what's up with you today and you say I'm
sad because of this person or this
circumstance I would say Oh you mean
that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think well anything that's
you think you're victim to so then when
things are good you feel good when
things are bad you feel bad right and if
you feel bad then you look for something
out there to make this feeling go away
but then when the when the novelty or
the event is over here comes that
feeling again and you got to go chase
something else
well the response for many people to
their environment is actually weakening
their body the stress response they
react to some event and their reaction
to the event is actually weakening the
organism now shortterm it's cool all
organisms can handle that but the
long-term effects of of that just
diminishes or taps the body's resources
of vital energy there's no energy to
heal there's no energy for growth and
repair so what we're
suggesting is that when the person
becomes less victim to their environment
and realizing that they're more of the
creator of their environment and they're
less the response to the environment
weakens them less cuz they know how to
self-regulate and
change they'll be less suscepti
to things in their environment large or
small
and creating a life that is Meaningful
for a person someone's young as you and
you start seeing that you're actually
creating
it you every time you get feedback a
breadcrumb from the universe saying
amelo keep going keep your keep your
head down keep going you're run going to
run into something big all of those
things are convincing you you that you
are not the victim to your life that
you're actually the creator of your life
and people who actually do this not that
you react the question is how long you
react and teaching people how to move
out of those States and back into
homeostasis back into balance by
self-regulating with their eyes open
getting so good at doing it in their
meditation with their eyes closed that
they could actually do it with their
eyes open in their life now it's a
different game so get enough
people uh in the world becoming less
reactive to their environment uh they're
less controlled uh by their environment
and the side effect of that is there's a
huge change in our biology huge I can I
could say right now with certainty I can
say that if people
commit to say as an example 7 Days of of
an event that we do I can say there will
be so many biological changes that take
place in our body we have the evidence
that says that uh that we have such
profound
hope uh for Humanity in what we're
discovering when the brain and the heart
are coherent my goodness there's a
feeling where you can call it the zone
or whatever you want to call it or just
you feel like you have enough time to
get things done and no person no
circumstance is going to break you from
your state right that that that zone or
whatever you want to call that is
actually teaching so do you have to
reach gamma to do that no we're just
knowing that the people that hit gamma
they had an instantaneous biological
upgrade there's the eczema MH 37 years
of eczema the next day it's gone back to
your original
question we have great evidence in
testimony and we have great evidence in
our scientific studies and evidence is
the loudest voice and you can't tell me
you're too old to do this you can't tell
me you're too sick to do this I've seen
people with 50 brain tumors that were
emaciated couldn't walk couldn't speak
on the stage talking in front of an AUD
can't tell me you're too sick to do this
now you examine that person you know who
comes to the event and there's no hope
you know they you have three months to
live you have six months to live and
they're not accepting that or believing
that are surrendering to that they're
actually saying there's got to be some
other way there's got to be some other
way if I created this is it possible
that I that that I can uncreate it so
then the person who's who's on the stage
telling that story and and it it may
have taken them 18 months but they never
missed a day why is that essential
because there were days where they felt
so bad in their body so sick that they
didn't feel like doing their meditation
but they did it anyway there were days
they had so much doubt because their
condition was actually worsening
and they could have succumbed to their
doubt but they they did their meditation
anyway there there were days that they
were in such incredible fear because the
doctor told them it was 3 months and it
would be over and it was the three-month
period and they had every reason to not
do their meditation but they did it
anyway they could have said I don't have
enough time I have kids I I got
schedules they found time to do it and
it was the
overcoming the overcoming the overcoming
that was the becoming process coming
becoming and and when they became that
person what is the side effect of your
own personal transformation for example
most people they when they have a
physical health condition the moment
they notice there's a change like in
pain in something and their sleep you
know whatever it is there's some
change they they make the connection
right away and that's when it's the dog
on The Bone now they're they're doing it
twice a day not because they have to
because that's their medicine and and
and I have sat with the the the
scientists that have come to our events
I asked them to participate in a week
long event and the one guy who's looking
at the virus outside the cell I said to
him one well how is this going to change
how is this going to change the way you
do research he said this is this is my
medicine this I see I've seen what it
does and people say oh are you saying
meditation actually can cause your body
be to resistant to viruses I no no no
know I'm not saying that the data is
saying that I'm not just this is not
what I'm saying the data is actually
saying that so what a great time in
history to be alive because you could be
young we have people that are 8 years
old 9 years old we have usually about
between 70 and 100 kids that come to our
event that are under the age of 25 and
under we have kids that are 7 eight nine
years old that participate all the way I
got down on my knees with one of those
one of these kids and we were we were
doing a um a specific meditation and I
leaned over and I said to him how is
that he said that felt really good and
why do I want that to be a normal
feeling for him cuz I want to know who
he's going to be yeah yeah we're
changing his you're changing his gene
expression at that age right and so so
so it's an amazing time this is a time
in history where it's not enough to know
this is a time in history to know how so
my interest to answer your question is
to demystify the process no different
than learning how to hit a golf ball
everybody that's has a skill that can do
anything really well has done the exact
same thing that I'm talking about
there's nothing different about it
living in stress is living in survival
and survival is a very primitive NE
mechanism that allows us to really
really adapt to an environment that's
threatening or dangerous the moment you
perceive a a danger or threat you switch
on an autonom function in your body the
sympathetic nervous system and there's
an
arousal the arousal of those hormones
causes a heightening of the senses
because now we want to become more acute
that there's a danger there if there's a
if there's a a tiger in the bushes and
you hear something rumbling around and
it's night you're going to either run
fight or freeze or or hide that's your
choices and so that works really well in
survival for the short term because the
arousal causes us feeling like we're
more our body we get a rush of energy
the arousal causes our brain waves to
change and to move into a more alert
State we now our focus on what it is in
the environment we're giving it our
attention all of our attention and now
we're trying to predict what's going to
happen in the future based on what we've
known in the past so we're overlaying a
known into the future so that we can
prepare and normally when we don't know
what it
is the unknown causes us to feel these
primitive emotions of survival and it's
best to run it's best to fear the
unknown
so the challenge
becomes that that works really well for
the short
term but when you switch on this system
and you're mobilizing enormous amounts
of the body's energy and resources for
some threat in your outer world there's
no energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building project
we start tapping the body's vital
resources and that's what creates mental
health or physical health or spiritual
disease right so because no organism can
live in that emergency state for that
extended period of time it's like
there's a hurricane coming through
Australia you're not going to be
thinking about remodeling your kitchen
at at that time it's not a time for
long-term projects right so now when
we're in stress and we're in survival
the self is the most important you don't
trust it's not a time to love it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to
communicate uh it's not a time to be
vulnerable it's not a time to open your
heart it's not the time to sit down and
close your eyes and go within you would
be eaten the survival Gene is switched
on and people spend 70% of their time
living in the state so then in that
state where the arousal takes place the
brain moves into a heightened brain wve
pattern called beta brain wave pattern
now as I said that's like driving your
sports car and first gear in the freeway
you it's it's the jump start but you
can't do it for a long period of time
because in
stress stress is signaled by the loss of
control not being able to predict the
next moment the unknown or the
perception that something's going to get
worse and when you're in that state you
start trying to control and predict
everything in your life and you shift
your attention from one person to
another person to another problem to
another thing to another place to
another object uh to a group of
situations and every every one of those
elements has a neurological Network in
the brain so the
arousal causes the brain like a
lightning storm in the clouds to start
firing out of order it starts firing
incoherently and when the brain is
incoherent we're incoherent when the
brain isn't working right we're not
working right so then now the person is
aroused in that state it's never
occurred to them that they could change
that in fact they're telling you I am
this way because of my boss because of
my ex because of my past because of the
news because of the global situation
whatever it is and what they're really
saying is I'm using something in my
outer
environment to validate or Justify why I
feel this way so then that means then
they're also going to be dependent on
something in their outdoor environment
to make them feel better whether it's a
drug or a a a treatment or whatever it
is uh complaining whatever it is that
makes them feel better and the moment
they notice that they've done something
and they've used something outside of
them to make that feeling go away
they'll pay attention to what it was and
every time they feel that feeling
they'll become dependent on it so now
they're more dependent on their
environment so then the subconscious
program is when things are good you feel
good but when things are bad you feel
bad so you're completely victim to your
environment and the environment is
actually controlling the way you feel
and
think now anything that controls the way
you feel and think you're victim too so
I say Glenn why are you in such a bad
mood I'm in a bad mood because of this
person this circumstance this this
situation in my life which I really
saying is something in my outer
environment is literally controlling my
feelings my emotions and my thoughts so
then it turns
out that when a person is in that state
and they're in that aroused State their
heart is beating because the sympathetic
nervous system switched on but they're
not running they're not fighting they're
not hiding they're stepping on the gas
pedal and they're stepping on the break
and the Heart starts beating very
incoherently and incoherent waves in the
brain and incoherent waves in the heart
diminish energy so energy goes out of
the brain energy goes out of the heart
we stop thinking clearly we stop
rationalizing very well we can't plan
for the future we're uninspired in our
heart we don't trust we can't feel
gratitude we can't feel appreciation we
can't feel love it's not a time to feel
any of those things so then that's the
beginning of disease right so the person
starts thinking about their problems and
they turn on that stress response just
by thought alone and if the hormones of
stress push the genetic buttons that
create disease then your thoughts are
going to make you
sick and the question is if your
thoughts can make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts can make you
well and by the same means if you're
using every person every circumstance in
your life to
reaffirm that dependency on that Rush of
emotions then you become addicted to the
life you don't even
like that's why change is so hard
because you'd rather suffer and be in
pain than take a chance in the unknown
because the unknown you can't predict it
so people cling to the familiar and
cling to the known and and so they
become dependent on the environment so
what we found out was is there a way to
make the brain more
coherent is there a formula that we can
teach people instead of narrowing their
focus on the material
world narrowing their focus on
everything known but if they brought bro
their focus and they put it on nothing
on Space if they broaden their focus and
they they they open their awareness uh
uh in this way what happens to the brain
and we found the brain gets really
organized what if they traded fear for
an elevated emotion and we taught them
how to start working with their body
first of all you know mo mothering is
the as I said is the hardest job in the
world and there's I I raised three kid
kids uh three children and and um I
practiced raising them within many of
these principles and it with
children uh number one thing is they
have mirror neurons and miror neurons
are called empathy neurons they they
Model Behavior when a lionist is
teaching her Cubs how to hunt she's not
on a chalkboard and saying you go here
you go there she's saying watch me do
this and when the Cubs watch the Lioness
hunt as they're looking at their mom
hunting they're priming the very
circuits in their brain to hunt as they
as they watch their mom they're becoming
their mom hunting and the the the
mother's Act is selecting and
instructing circuitry in their brain
equal to the environment that they're
perceiving so what does that mean to an
adult or a human being you got to be the
example of everything you want your
children to be that's that's the fast PA
path to Enlightenment so you can't tell
your kids get off your technology while
you're over there on the computer on the
phone or on the TV and expect them to
find something to do if you're not
engaging um it's important to have
technology but it's also important to
not have technology and and that's
healthy as well so one of the cool
things that's happened in our our
community is we
have hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of kids that come to our
week-long events from the age of seven
or six all the way up to you know 25 and
26 and sometimes there's 200 on the
stage and the children are interested in
understanding that they can create a
better life and so there's certain
principles I think that really help
parents and of course another one is
never try to
reason with your children when they're
emotional because we don't want to be
reasoned with when we're emotional we
want to be left alone until we get
through the emotion because no
information could actually enter their
brain that isn't equal to that emotional
state
now one of the most important things
that I think you can teach a child by
demonstration as as well as story
allegory and conversation is to teach
them how to shorten the refractory
period of their emotional responses so
as I said you react to or respond to
something or some condition in your
outer world uh that changes your
emotional state it could create fear it
could create anger create jealousy
hostility Envy
whatever and so then the the lingering
of that emotion that chemical if you
allow it to last for for days to weeks
it's called a mood if it lasts for weeks
and weeks uh two months on end that's
called a temperament oh he's an angry
temperament why are you angry I'm angry
because of this experience if you keep
the same emotion going on for years on
end that's called a personality
personality trait so personality traits
many times are created by the
experiences and the emotions that that
the keep us connected to the Past
teaching children how to shorten their
emotional
reactions is such such so vitally
important because when we're in that
emotional state there's a gap between
the way things appear and the way things
really are we're altered we're not
ourselves and if we act during that time
if we send an email during that time if
we speak during that time even if we
think during that
time
and we follow through we'll normally say
I should have never said that I never
should have never thought that I never
sent that email I should have never done
it so children then are so neuroplastic
it's so important for you to have
conversations with them about how hard
it is to overcome our emotional states
when we're in the emotional state as an
example my with my daughter my
kids whenever I saw her react to someone
or something whatever I was doing as
long as there was no injury or there no
one was in danger I would stop and I
turn around and I would observe her just
for a minute while she was doing what
she was reacting to and she became aware
that I was observing her after she
became aware that I was observing her
then I would deal with it however I had
to deal with
it at the end of the day I would lay
down with my children in bed and I would
start to talk about myself God I had a
pretty tough day
today I lost it right around 3:00 I
couldn't get back the entire day I was
frustrated and I was impatient had too
many things going on I was
overwhelmed and I wasn't pre present
with you guys at
dinner I don't know making something
up if you just pause for a
moment my daughter would say yeah I got
really angry at Paris today and I'd say
I no I saw
you and I and then she'd say yeah she
start telling me what happened I'd say
okay now that you know what happened if
it happened
again how would you do it differently
how would you behave differently how
would you evolve your experience and
then we would talk about it and between
her and I we would come up with another
plan another rehearsal we would begin to
okay let's let's Okay so Paris comes in
she say and you do this and said and so
you're before you go to bed at night
your subconscious mind is wide open to
information and so I would rehearse it
with her before she would go to sleep
well you know while the everybody was in
bed and I would then tell a story of
these kids that lived in a far away land
and then I would bring in each kid's
little allegory about them and what they
were working on changing to to give them
an opportunity that they could evolve
their experience
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 3
hours of pure Joe despenza inspiration
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and instead of
getting up and getting on your cell
phone and getting distracted sit with
your triple filtered water or a glass of
wine or whatever you're into the
question without being distracted the
contemplation process is the building
process neurologically